Here's an interesting thing,
so one of the postmodernists claims is
that diversity is necessary and they
make it racial and they make it sexual.
They may get ethnic and all of that.
That's actually technically incorrect by
the way,
because
I study individual differences,
so those are the differences between
people and I know the literature.
So you know about James Damore memo
right from Google.
He wrote that partly because he was
watching my videos,
which is why he wanted me to interview
him and I'm a believer that there are
biological differences in temperament
between men and women apart from the
other obvious differences and that
they're actually not trivial and that
they maximizing in the societies that
have the most have moved farthest to
producing egalitarian states,
the Scandinavian countries,
and that.
The reason for that is that there's two
reasons why men and women different
temperament.
One is biological and the other is
environmental,
and if you remove the environmental
variation,
which you do,
if you make the state egalitarian,
you maximize the genetic variation and
that's been demonstrated in the
scientific literature over about four
decades and no one wanted it or hope for
it and they weren't biased and looking
for it because that was exactly the
opposite of what social scientists
wanted to find because social scientists
lean heavily to the left and what they
wanted to find was you flatten out the
state so that everyone has equal
opportunity and the differences between
people disappear.
That is not what happened.
The opposite happened that wasn't wrong
and no one was happy about it and no
one's happy about it.
Now you can actually tell when you've
discovered something in the social
science because you're not happy about
it,
but
if you take.
Let's say there's a big difference
between men and women in terms of trait,
agreeableness,
compassion and politeness.
On average,
women are more agreeable than men and
the difference is approximately this.
If you take random pairs of men and
women out of the population,
let's say you had to make a bet on who
was more agreeable,
if you bet that it was the woman,
you'd be right 60 percent of the time,
well that's not that much means you'd be
wrong.
Forty percent of the time,
that's almost 50 percent of the time,
so this is a big difference by social
science standards,
but that's the magnitude of the
difference.
There are some differences that are
bigger,
like the difference between men and
women's interest in people versus things
is actually bigger than that.
That's the biggest difference we know,
but it's a big difference.
Let's say the agreeable this difference,
but still they the shared attributes of
men and women far outweigh the
attributes that differentiate them
because you could ask are there more
differences within groups or between
them?
Now the postmodern answered that is
between them.
That's why you need diversity by group,
right?
That's why you need different races.
That's why you need different
ethnicities,
sexual preferences and all of that.
Well,
that's wrong.
There's more differences within the
groups and there is between them.
You don't get diversity by crossing the
groups.
You get diversity by group,
by selecting across individuals.
In fact,
the idea that there is more differences
between groups said there is between
individuals is actually the fundamental
racist idea is the fundamental racist
idea,
which is,
well,
let's say you're Asian Oriental to use
the old word to discriminate the one
type of Asian say from the other.
You're so different from me that there's
no overlap between our groups and you're
also so different and there's so little
difference within your group that now
that I know that you're not me,
you're not one of mine.
I actually know what you're like,
no,
technically that's incorrect.
That's wrong.
That isn't how you get diversity.
Now diversity is actually necessary
because people,
different intelligence and they
different temperament and the different
skills and so you actually need
diversity because otherwise you can't
take advantage of all those differences.
So you need diversity,
but you need genuine diversity and like
what would genuine diversity mean?
If you're trying to put together a work
team,
you want enough,
you want people have sufficient
diversity so that they more or less so
that you gathered together the
appropriate talents to produce the
implement that's necessary to work
properly in the world.
That's a competence marker because
otherwise your business is going to fail
and so the proper diversity with regards
to employment is the diversity that
meets the requirements of the business
essentially.
Obviously that's why you try to hire
people carefully and not randomly.
Let's say.